(slow classical string music)
(hip hop music)
- Hello, I'm Tiara Kelly
and I've been dancing since
I was seven years old.
Twerking, for me,
represents just being free
and moving my hips and like,
I like twerking, it's just like, natural.
(classical music)
- Ballet's being going
on for so many years,
it's centuries of years old
and it's very traditional.
- The hardest part about ballet
is definitely the technical parts of it
like staying turned out all the time
and pointing your feet and
straightening your legs
and all the placement.
- In all my time dancing
there's never been much of a mention
of anything besides ballet.
- [Amanda] I think twerking's really cool.
I've never done it.
- I'm about to teach them how to twerk
and they gonna go to the club tonight.
So get into first position and plié,
and out to second, and plié,
and stay there and then
you're gonna pop the booty.
(hip hop music)
Yeah.
[laughing]
- I've twerked in my own mind.
I don't remember a lot of it.
There's un-sober twerking.
- Hey, hey, hey
and if you want you can go to the side.
- Hey!
- And go to the other side.
- Go all the way down
and go back to the right.
- I'm like, falling.
I don't know if my body can twerk.
- And then go back to the middle
and move your hips in a circle.
Not your whole body, just your hips.
- It's a lot to think about.
- All right, we're just
gonna get down dirty.
We're gonna get down to the floor,
we're gonna get on our knees,
and we're gonna crawl back and forth.
And if you want, you can
put a little arch into it.
And arch your back from behind.
So everybody drop down and pop
your butt at the same time.
You can do it.
Don't think about it.
- Don't think guys, just don't think.
The tip is just not to think.
- [Tiara] Just don't think.
We are ready to take it
to the obstacle course.
We're gonna go across the floor.
You're gonna start with
your hands behind your head
and you're gonna kick with your right
and then kick with your left
and come down with your
hands on your knees
and back it up three times,
one, two, three.
And then you're gonna
drop down to your knees
and go across the floor, one, two.
You guys can do it.
(hip hop music)
("Miss V.I.P.")
- I feel fantastic after
learning how to twerk.
I think I'll be incorporating
twerking into my daily life.
- It was just kinda like
a freedom and movement
and it was so fun.
- I am going to play a trick
game while I'm in class now
that like, every time
the teacher turns around
I'ma just twerk.
- I feel like a superstar
cause I got everybody
to learn how to twerk
and everybody's so excited to dance.